THOUGHTS.
>> Laura: POLITICAL
AFFILIATION DOES NOT EQUAL
SEDITION, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
GENTLEMEN, GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
WHILE BIDEN TURNS NATIONAL
SECURITY AGAINST NATIONAL
SECURITIES.
HE LET THE BORDER BECOME A
NATIONAL NIGHTMARE.
ON TRACK TO TAKE A RECORD 16,000
MIGRANT USE.
AND THEY ARE ALL IN CUSTODY.
BUT HAVE NO FEAR BECAUSE BIDEN
ANNOUNCED HE WAS WASTING THIS
JOB ON TO VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS.
THE SAME PERSON WITH POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY SAID SOMETHING A
LITTLE DISTURBING A FEW YEARS
AGO.
>> I WOULD NOT PUT CHILDREN IN
CAGES.
SPEAK WITH THE HUMAN RIGHTS
BEING COMMITTED BY THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THIS TO HAPPEN, NOT ON THEIR
WATCH.
>> I THOUGHT CHILDREN LINED UP
SINGLE FILE BASED ON GENDER
BEING WALKED INTO BARRACKS.
THESE CHILDREN SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED LIKE CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: SHE IS CRITICIZING
HER OWN ADMINISTRATION BACK
THEN.
NEWT GINGRICH FORMER HOUSE
SPEAKER, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
IS THAT KIND OF THE KISS OF
DEATH GIVING THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE OF
FIXING THE BORDER GIVEN HER
PAST COMMENTS ABOUT THE WAY THE
BORDER WAS ENFORCED?
>> FIRST OF ALL IT IS VERY
CLEVER BIDEN ON THIEVE OF THE
PRESS CONFERENCE TO TURN IT OVER
TO HER SO EVERY QUESTION
TOMORROW ABOUT THE BORDER, HE
CAN SAY THAT IS VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS’ JOB AND YOU NEED TO TALK
TO HER ABOUT IT, NEXT QUESTION.
IN THAT SENSE, HE DUCKS ALL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT IS NOT A
CRISIS BUT A DISASTER.
IT IS GETTING WORSE.
92% OF HISPANIC-AMERICANS WANT
EVERY PERSON WHO COMES INTO THIS
COUNTRY TESTED FOR COVID.
90%, OVERALL, OF ALL AMERICANS
WANT THEM TESTED FOR COVID.
THERE IS NO POSSIBILITY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL DO THAT.
I THINK WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS IS A VERY
GOOD POLITICIAN AND PRESENTLY
WILL EXPLAIN THE WONDERFUL
THINGS ARE, AND THAT TRUST ME IT
IS OKAY.
SHE WILL GO ON TO SOMETHING ELSE
ELSE.
HER FUTURE IS NOT DEPENDENT ON
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE BORDER.
HER FUTURE IS DEPENDENT ON WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE ONE BREAKING TONIGHT, THE
PENTAGON IS APPROVING AN HHS
REQUEST TO TEMPORARY HOUSE
UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT CHILDREN
EMBANKMENT DORMITORIES IN
SAN ANTONIO, TEXAS.
AND AN AREA OF LAND IN
FORT BLISS TO CONSTRUCT A
SUITABLE TEMPORARY HOUSING
FACILITY.
NEWT, WHY THE HECK DOES A
MILITARY GET INVOLVED IN THIS?
>> IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BUILD
THE WALL, YOU ARE GOING TO BUILD
A LOT OF DORMITORIES.
THAT IS A SIMPLE EQUATION.
THEY ARE PRESENTLY, THEY ARE
GOING TO DROWNED AND PEOPLE WHO
COME NORTH.
AND EVERY TIME THERE IS A TV
STORY ABOUT THIS, MORE PEOPLE
COME UP.
THEY ARE NOT OFF IN
CENTRAL AMERICA WHO ARE FINDING
PEOPLE FROM AFRICA, FROM CHINA,
FROM INDIA, FROM TURKEY HERE
THERE IS A CONTINUING WAVE
COMING TO THE U.S.
THERE IS ESSENTIALLY A PEACEFUL
INVASION BY A HUGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE BY THE SUMMER THERE MAY
BE WELL OVER 100 PEOPLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT.
THIS WHOLE THING WILL FALL
APART.
BUT WHAT THEY WILL DO IS WHAT
THEY DO ALL ALONG.
THEY WILL JUST LIE.
>> Laura: NEWT, ARE WE TO
BELIEVE THIS WILL NOT AFFECT THE
POOREST AMERICANS THE MOST?
THE INFLUX OF MOSTLY POOR AND
OBVIOUSLY NONENGLISH SPEAKING
MIGRANTS INTO THE UNITED STATES?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS
WHAT I SUPPORT FOR TESTING FOR
COVID HIGH AMONG HISPANICS AND
ALL-AMERICANS.
THE FIRST THAT WILL BE EFFECTIVE
IS RELATIVELY POOR PEOPLE WHO
WILL HAVE INFECTED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN TESTED, HAVE NOT
BEEN TRACKED, WHO HAVE NOT HAD
MEDICAL HELP SHOWING UP IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
YOU KNOW, THROUGH ALL OF THESE
THINGS AT THE AIRPORT, ALL OF
THESE TESTS AT THE AIRPORT, THEN
WE HAVE A POLICY UNDER BIDEN
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO COME IN
HERE.
SECOND, YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE POOREST AMERICANS WILL HAVE
THEIR WAGES SUPPRESSED BY THIS
COMPETITION.
AND THIRD, EVERY TAXPAYER WILL
GET HIT.
WE WILL PROVIDE SHELTER, FOOD,
WE WILL PROVIDE EDUCATION.
THEN WE WILL PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE TAKING ON HERE BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS.
>> Laura: AND 42 A MILLION